von schwarzen löchern wissen wir
eigentlich nur so viel dass wir nichts
über sie wissen oder nur sehr wenig sie
sind das größte rätsel im universum
entdeckt wurden die schwarzen löcher auf
dem papier einmal einstein kam im rahmen
der allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
darauf dass es schwarze löcher geben
könnte himmelskörper deren masse so groß
ist dass selbst licht sie nicht
verlassen kann
ihre anziehungskraft ihre gravitation
ist zu groß er war aber davon überzeugt
dass die natur ein solches ungetüm nicht
zulassen würde aber da hat er sich
geirrt anfang der 1970 er jahre war es
dann soweit
es wurde immer klarer zyklus x1 ist ein
doppelsternsystem bestehend aus einem
blauen riesen und eben einen schwarzen
loch einem winzigen schwarzen loch mit
einem durchmesser von rund 300
kilometern aber damit fangen die rätsel
erst wenn das was sich da im inneren
abspielt ist vollkommen unerforscht und
im moment sieht es nicht so aus dass wir
je erfahren werden was im inneren eines
schwarzen loches vor sich geht nur eines
ist gewiss schwarze löcher stellen die
physik so wie wir sie hier auf der erde
erleben vollkommen auf den kopf
da passieren dinge die vollkommen
unmöglich erscheinen und das hat mit
albert einstein zu tun
viele menschen glauben ja immer noch das
gravitation so was wie eine kraft ist
massen ziehen sich gegenseitig eben an
unter uns das ist aber tatsächlich ein
viertel oder massen ziehen sich nicht an
und das was wir hier auf der erde
erleben ist ein phänomen das in der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie von
albert einstein beschrieben wird
große massen verzerren die raumzeit so
dass eine coole entsteht eine vertiefung
in die alles hinein fällt was in der
nähe ist ein betttuch ist eigentlich ein
ganz gutes modell um das zu erklären das
ist die raumzeit jetzt und eine gestirn
liegt dort wie ein ball drin und alles
was in die nähe
dieses balles gerät das feld in die
kuhle die er in der raumzeit verursacht
hat und noch etwas ist paradox und führt
zu einer verblüffenden schlussfolgerung
in der erde ist nämlich mehr platz als
eigentlich da wäre wieso die
erdanziehungskraft staucht alles etwas
zusammen würden wir also lineale durch
die erde quer durch legen um den
durchmesser auszumessen würden die einen
größeren durchmesser messen als er
tatsächlich da ist weil sie ja
zusammengedrückt werden durch die
gravitation dies gilt aber für alle
materie innerhalb der erdkugel
das heißt tatsächlich passt mehr in die
erde hinein als es eigentlich sein
könnte
was ist dann aber bei einem schwarzen
loch der fall
es gibt wissenschaftler die glauben dass
in einem schwarzen noch wie dem von
zyklus x1 dass er einen durchmesser von
300 kilometern hat tatsächlich nur ein
gestirn enthalten ist mit einer größe
eines stecknadel kopfes sie bezeichnen
das als singularität das ist noch viel
kleiner als ein stecknadelkopf das ist
unvorstellbar klein allerdings mit einem
riesigen volumen da durch die
gravitation die krümmung der raumzeit in
diesem mini mini mini gestirn wahnsinnig
viel platz entstanden ist die 300
kilometer durchmesser die besagen nur
die größe des ereignisses horizontes
dass es genau die grenze ab der alles
unwiederbringlich vom schwarzen loch
aufgesogen wird also auch licht und
deshalb sind die löcher schwarz
außerhalb dieses ereignis horizont haben
licht und materie noch eine kleine
chance davon zu kommen haben sie diese
grenze allerdings überschritten
ja dann haben wir keine ahnung was da
passiert die einen sagen wir werden wie
spaghetti auseinander gezogen weil die
gravitation in der nähe der singularität
also der mitte des schwarzen loches
immer größer wird und es gibt auch
welche die sagen ja das ist das tor in
eine andere
version in ein anderes universum oder
oder oder wir wissen es nicht aber wie
entsteht eigentlich ein schwarzes loch
es sind wohl so anderthalb bis
zweieinhalb sonnenmassen nötig damit ein
schwarzes loch überhaupt entstehen kann
wenn wir ein stern dieser größe die
fusion zum erliegen kommt weil der
brennstoff verbrannt ist
dann gibt es keine kraft mehr keinen
strahlungsdruck mehr der der gravitation
entgegenwirkt kräfte in den atomen
reichen dann auch nicht mehr aus um der
gravitation entgegenzuwirken
die sterne stürzen in sich zusammen aber
wird der stern immer immer kleiner
die gravitation nimmt immer weiter zu
und beschleunigt den prozess noch wenn
also ein stern ausreichend groß ist wird
er über kurz oder lang zum schwarzen
loch die gravitation ist also für die
entstehung von gestürmt genauso
verantwortlich wie für die
selbstzerstörung wenn sie am schluss in
sich zusammenstürzen
und es gibt noch eine ganz spezielle art
von schwarzen löchern
das sind die supermassereichen schwarzen
löcher sie sind riesig
bzw ereignishorizont wir wissen ja nicht
wie groß die gestirne darin sind und sie
befinden sich in der mitte von galaxie
im zentrum der milchstraße also der
galaxie in der sich unser sonnensystem
befindet da ist so ein schwarzes loch
mit mehr als vier millionen kommen
lassen
aber woher es kommt und ob es dafür
verantwortlich ist dass es unsere
galaxie überhaupt gibt das sind fragen
die zur zeit noch nicht geklärt sind und
der satellit fermi erkennt denn der hat
den legendären kamerablitz entdeckt der
hat was unglaubliches spektakuläres rund
um dieses schwarze loch entdeckt wie bei
einem gammablitze wagen aus der region
um das schwarze loch im zentrum unserer
galaxie zwei riesige blasen ins weltall
mit einer mit einem durchmesser von 25
tausend lichtjahren umso mehr wir uns
mit schwarzen löchern beschäftigen umso
mehr fragen gibt es und auch ein paar
wenige antworten
wir können also extrem gespannt sein was
da alles noch
das war es also zum thema schwarze
löcher vielen dank für die zahlreichen
anregungen sich mit diesem thema zu
beschäftigen wenn ihr themenvorschläge
habt schreibt sie hier unten in die
kommentare zum nachlesen gibt's das
ganze nochmal auf dem blog klick.de und
wenn ihr wissen wollt was man so alles
für feuerzauber mit kakao und
wunderkerzen anstellen kann dann guckt
das letzte video von pixum bis dann
bleibt dran